if you look back and regret things that  happen in your life you'll be very  miserable the hardest thing in life to  do is to be happy that's the most  elusive thing in life achieving personal  happiness and I'm pretty happy I got  lucky in life and I'm reasonably happy  with where I am now I wish I was younger  looking I wish I didn't have all this  gray hair I wish I could lose more  weight I wish I was in Greater shape but  generally I'm reasonably happy and if  you're Jewish that's hard to do  so some reasonably happy  um  um but you know I I recognize that  happiness is difficult to achieve and  many people in life go through life not  being very happy they're sad that  they're not wealthier handsome or  whatever it is and they never Achieve  Personal happiness you have to accept  where you are and try to make the best  of it within reason you can obviously  try to do better